roger ailes one of the most influential
and controversial figures in cable news
died this morning the founder and
longtime chairman of Fox News was forced
out last year of a sexual harassment
allegations and awareness is with us and
a good morning
good morning Roger Ailes was a Titan of
the broadcast industry helping Rupert
Murdoch launch Fox News more than two
decades ago he made the channel one of
the most influential TV networks but his
career ended in scandal we learned some
sad news this morning that our former
CEO Roger Ailes passed away this morning
for two decades Roger Ailes help build
Fox News from the ground up we invested
a lot in politics from day one
Yael spoke to Charlie Rose in 2001 and
we think that politics is really
America's favorite indoor space and
whether whether you know people talk
about it they vote they don't vote they
all have opinions about the issues
before his time at Fox News Ailes was a
well-known political consultant working
with presidents Richard Nixon Ronald
Reagan and George HW Bush caution you
are about to enter the no spin zone
Ailes was essential in helping Fox News
rise to power behind personalities like
Bill O'Reilly who recently left the
network over sexual harassment
allegations but was one of its biggest
stars for years I am Bill O'Reilly
thanks for watching us tonight we kind
of created people like Bill O'Reilly we
didn't create him in a sense that Bill's
been around for 25 years but we gave him
a forum to do his thing in primetime but
the philosophy is two dead in primetime
you have to create personalities is that
the idea yeah you have to create ratings
I mean in the end it's about ratings and
if you can't get rated you don't survive
last year Ailes ran into his own
troubles at the network he resigned in
July in the wake of sexual harassment
allegations and a mountain of negative
publicity in a statement Ailes wife said
Roger was a loving husband he was also a
patriot profoundly grateful to live in a
country that gave him so much
opportunity Ailes was 77 years old
Gail Anna thank you